[Music]
I want to take you guys back on a little
walk down memory lane July 29th actually
marked the 20-year anniversary of your
debut album oh yeah Wow yeah 20 years
what do you remember most about that
time well it seems like yesterday really
I mean I mean in that particular time I
think we were driving ourselves around
in a Winnebago that was wrapped with our
pictures in it and we were on it and we
were out there hustling and doing
grassroots promotion
[Music]
this germinated from a dream that we had
together and all of a sudden we're out
there the albums and stores were
actually going into stores ourselves and
by driving ourselves in more and pull
into a town and call the radio station
and request our own song as many times
as we possibly could to try and like
okay guys we got it we got it we you
know in those days you're just doing
anything and everything you can to get
yourself recognized you know and we did
it like the real kind of oh no I wanna
go down the line and ask you each to
give yourselves your younger selves a
piece of advice
oh good lord there's lots of things
don't take it so seriously enjoy it more
have more fun with it it's funny cuz we
tell these stories about 20 years ago
and as I'm sitting here talking about it
those were those were some of the best
memories of the whole ride for me is
that is those early days when it was
just us kind of us against the world I
don't know that we necessarily
appreciated it as much in the moment
because we were so tired and and so
nervous about was gonna happen but yeah
maybe you I have to view enjoy smell the
roses
it's not often I agree with this idiot
to be more original
[Music]
stay away from Sally she's trouble I
don't have many regrets
so yes well there was no sound we took
it very seriously I mean that was our
entire lives you know what I mean and
now it's like we're enjoying it it you
know take a deep breath take it in you
know we're getting interviewed still
having fun still doing music together I
would have told Mike I might get myself
20 years ago change your hair some
clothing issues original I think
everybody went through that though in
the night
[Music]
you